Tom yeah so as you heard my name is
David Smith and I'm pressing Betty and
Jared gave me a great introduction so
you've probably heard everything you
need to know about me so with that I'm
gonna jump right into the talk and yes I
as you might have guessed from the entry
music this talk was inspired by an
episode of Silicon Valley
I'd have anybody saw this episode from
season four where jinyang builds an app
on his phone that he could point at food
and it will tell you what the food was
except that it only worked for hot dogs
funny thing about this at this episode
only aired last year in May last year
and at that time the whole concept that
you could have and I the way the time is
not going down here guys the whole
concept that you could have a an app
that you could point at anything and it
would tell you what was in the picture
was complete fantasy nonetheless the
producers did build exactly this app
they use tensorflow
and uploaded it to core ml and ran it on
a device actual thing was an Android
device now that I think about it they
have a really good blog post that
explains the process that used to
actually build this model from scratch
and train it and it was quite pioneering
and today you know this kind of stuff is
pretty routine and in fact what I'm
going to show you in this talk today is
how you can build exactly an app like
this an app that takes a picture you
take a picture you points it out
something that may or may not be a hot
dog and it'll tell you if it is or is
not a hot dog
and the way I'm going to do that is by
starting with getting some images of hot
dogs that I'm going to train a model
with and I'm gonna get those images from
a place called imagenet and I'll show
you how to do that in a little while
then we're going to train a recognizer
using a process called transfer learning
and the really nice thing about this is
you don't need to do that from scratch
I'm actually going to use an online
service in the azure cloud to do that
and drive all that computation using art
but the end result of this is we're
going to get a shiny app that we can use
we can give it a picture or a URL of a
picture it was analyze that picture and
tell us whether or not it's a hot dog so
let's see how to build one of those
before I do that though I want to do a
little bit of explanation about computer
vision and I'm going to gloss over many
many many details during this very brief
explanation but if you do want to go
into the details of how this works and
particularly the mathematics behind how
computer vision works
I really recommend Brandon roars blog he
explains it and really clear and easy to
understand away so check that out
and in particular I borrowed this
particular image from from Brandon's
blog but let's have a look at how
computer vision works the basic idea
behind computer vision is we have a
neural network which is basically a big
bunch of matrix operations we start off
with an image here's a picture of my
bicycle and that image all the pixels
that image goes to this node right here
and what happens at that node is a
filter is applied a filter in exactly
the same sense as a filter in Instagram
or snapchat that filter is defined by a
small number of weights that get applied
to pixels typically nine weights or four
weights but it's just a simple
mathematical operation which transforms
that picture changes it somehow and
makes it a little bit smaller in the
process same thing here we do the same
kind of process with a different filter
here different filter here different
filter here we get four new images we
combine the four images
which makes the image smaller again a
new filter a new filter a new filter
another layer in the neural network same
process happens again
so as we apply all these pictures these
filters rather and combine the pictures
together we're inferring more and more
information somehow about that picture
this particular neural network is a very
small one by computer vision standards
it only has four hidden layers but it's
also only designed to detect four
different classes of objects it's a
design subject dogs bicycles apples and
tennis balls and you can see that as we
take this picture of a bicycle and
process it from filter to filter to
filter the image gets smaller and
smaller and smaller until at the very
last layer we combine everything
together and that entire picture has
converted to one number which has been Z
between 0 & 1 which you can think of as
the probability or the confidence that
the picture represents one of these four
classes and you can see that in this
particular case it's working well for
this bicycle because that's the one that
gets the highest score and this neural
network would classify this picture as a
bicycle well how do we get to this stage
well we train it with thousands and
thousands possibly even millions of
images and we choose the weights of all
of those filters such that pictures of
bicycles get the highest score here
pictures of dogs get the highest score
here and so on and so forth how does
that work it doesn't matter it's really
just an optimization problem
it's just log likelihood if you like it
it's not likely but it's very very
similar there are great tools out there
that do this optimization process you
don't care anything about back
propagation or rally or anything like
that just know that these weights are
optimized such that this condition holds
true so that's the way basic computer
vision works what if we want to classify
pictures that are not one of those
classifications that the train you'll
network is designed to recognize in our
case what if we want to recognize
something other than dogs apples tennis
balls or bicycles what if we want to
identify hot dogs instead now of course
we could go back to the drawing broad
get millions of pictures of hot dogs
train one of those
networks in the same way but that takes
a lot of time takes a lot of money takes
a lot of computation but there's a
shortcut that lets us do just as well
with much less data and much less time
and that's called transfer learning we
could take that same network that we
just trained already to detect dogs and
bicycles and so forth strip out the last
layer that does the classification and
instead take a new image run it through
that pre train you will network and then
just grab the numbers that exist in that
second-to-last layer we don't know what
those numbers really represent but that
we call them features we get eight
numbers for every image F 1 F 2 F 3 or 4
or 5 or 6 F 7 and their fate and then
what we can do is take some pictures
that represent the classification that
we want to detect with transfer learning
let's take hot dogs let's start with
something there's not a hot dog it's a
picture of a burrito
we can run it through that network and
it's going to give us eight numbers and
a binary classification 0 or 1 let's do
it again for picture of a hot dog this
time run it through that same network we
get eight numbers and a binary
classification and we can do that again
and again and again for a couple of
hundred pictures so we get a couple of
hundred sets of eight numbers a couple
of hundred binary classifications what
does that sound like to you
that's just logistic regression right we
could build a pretty simple model which
given this data predicts this
classification and it turns out it works
pretty well we don't really know why
except in the sense that this whole
process of applying filters when you get
down to this last layer you can imagine
each of these data points here as
representing something intrinsic about
the image generally we don't really know
what as I said but this one might
represent the greenness of an image this
one might represent the number of
circles in the image this one might
represent if it was working with faces
the number of eyes that it's a text
those kinds of things
it's very pretty difficult to figure out
what they represent but when you apply
new images to them and do this
reclassification process it turns out it
works pretty well especially when you
use a network that's trained on images
that are somewhat like what your work
with so in my case I'm actually going to
work with a network that was trained on
food items and it turns out well that it
attacks features of food pictures really
well that makes this classification
works really well alright and you don't
even have to code this up yourself
there's a nice service that it's
available in Microsoft Azure called
Microsoft cognitive services custom
vision which let you just take a bunch
of images that represent the classes
that you want to detect so in my case
I'm going to give it a bunch of images
of hot dogs and a bunch of images of
things that look kind of like hot dogs
that are not so it can discriminate a
bit better I can just upload and upload
them to this service and it will build
one of these transfer learning models
for me has a nice for the web UI here's
an example for this particular project
that I'm working on here where I've got
61 pictures of hot dogs 78 pictures of
things that look like hot dogs but or
not and you know you can do with all
this kind of stuff through the GUI but
that didn't work for me in this
particular case because although you can
just upload a bunch of pictures from a
folder into that service I don't have
pictures in this case because I went to
image nets to get pictures of hot dogs
if you're looking for general a source
of general images by classifications
image net dog is a really useful service
it's a website that's been going for
about ten years to drive competitions in
image analysis which is actually what
generated these pre trained models that
we're using today you can regard people
search for hot dog but what you get out
of that if you download things is just a
list of URLs that represent the hot dogs
on the web and so it would have been a
real pain for me to go to each of these
and download them and then upload them
into the service so instead I used our
and interfaced with the API for custom
vision to do this so to get my images to
work with I searched for hot dogs in
image nets and also things that were
later like frankfurter buns that gave me
about 2300 URLs to work with similarly
for my contrast set you know things that
look like hot dogs but are not actually
hot dogs I look for tacos and hamburgers
and got about 2600 images for that
but I don't need that many it turns out
you only need you know a couple of
hundred images for transfer learning to
work well in a pre trained Network
that's related to your field so I just
sampled a hundred from each of those
lists using are all the code for this by
the way I'll give you an agate hub
repository at the end of the talk and
then I just wrote a function in R to
upload them to the custom vision service
this work is a is a key to access the
service and you can get that for free
from Azure details in the blog post but
here's the function I use upload URLs I
give it my vector of of URLs and the tag
I'm using and it uploads them into the
system and you get what you saw in the
previous slide there is a bit of a
problem with this however working with
data with image net at least and that is
when you search for hot dogs you get
things like this as I said that image is
that that site's been going for about 10
years many of the images are on Flickr
and when images are deleted from Flickr
it's not quite enough to give you a 404
it just gives you a black screen like
this no it gives you this this little
icon which is an image but it's not an
image of a hot dog so we need to figure
out how to do with that
I've lost my monitor there's my monitor
as well okay here is another image of a
hot dog that you get by searching for
hot dogs in in imagenet it's a woman who
is eating something that is not a hot
dog but is apparently an ice-cream
sandwich so we wouldn't want to have
that in our image sense but raining and
here's another example it's adorable
it's gone it was adorable
but it's not a hot dog so there is a
decent amount of data cleaning that you
would need to do to make this work and
of course you could have a look at those
URLs individually and just remove them
from your vector in our before your
upload but actually this is one of the
things that the web interface is really
convenient for you can actually browse
through the images select ones that you
want to retag or delete and in this case
it's my little dog and we'll get rid of
the dog go out by pressing delete
so that was how I could have filtered
out or cleaned up my data before my
transfer learning training
and after that process is complete you
can see about 61 images of hot dogs
there are all sorts of sort of
categories if you guessed sometimes
there's multiple hot dogs sometimes
there's other things in the image like a
person or other bits of food sometimes
it's a bit blurry but you know this is
the kind of data that we're using to do
training as we'll see it works pretty
good
and then for things that might be
mistaken for hot dogs TECO's hamburgers
and so forth I've got those in there
under another tag to do the training so
now when we want to do the training
we've got our images uploaded into
custom vision we tag them as hot dog and
not hot dog when you do the training you
have to choose something called a domain
which is the pre trained network that's
used to do the transfer learning when
they strip off the last set of
categories there are domains that have
been classes been trained rather with
just all sorts of images and that's
generic there's one that's been trained
with landmarks is one that's been
retrained with photos they might see in
our online shopping catalog for retail
applications there's one that's been
trained with adult images we just mainly
use for content filtering when people
upload bad stuff the one I use is the
one that's been trained on food items
which is why this works so well with so
few images you can't just click a button
in the API sorry in the web site rather
to launch the training process but I
wanted to kick it off from our so I can
automate this and this is just an
example of how we interfacing with the
API directly there's a very nice API
that's all documented online and with
the HTT our library which is lovely I
can just interface directly with the
endpoint that kicks off training and
then just check it for a few times until
it's completed because the training
takes about 30 seconds and happens
asynchronously asynchronously but once
that is done I have a trained model that
I can pump an image into before that
it's worthwhile having a look at how
well your model is doing and you can
have a look on the website to do this it
shows you these machine learning turns
precision and recall which I can never
remember what they mean I just remember
that this one is the false positives you
know of all the images in our database
how many were incorrectly classified and
and this is the impact of false
negatives of the
that weren't the thing when did it
classify as as the other thing and of
course this is all dependent on our
probability threshold remember that
number that came up at the very end that
was between zero and one we can choose
how high that number has to be before we
classify it as either that thing or that
other thing
and so we how you choose that number
depends on how the box is how many false
positive and how many false negatives
you get think about that carefully it
doesn't matter too much what I'm trying
to classify hot dogs but if you're
trying to classify say cancer from an
image x-ray the impact of a false
positive is a lot worse than the impact
of a false negative so how you choose
that number is really really important
depending on the application all right
next slide once we have trained the
model we have a I've written a function
in our code hot dog predicts I can just
pass it in a URL and URL and that
threshold that determines the
classification and the same kind of
thing again just get to the end point
passing the image URL and get the
response as JSON from the API and then
using the JSON package I can just
extract out the predictions for that
particular classification so I could do
that from the our command line really
easily so here is the URL of some hot
dogs on the grill and it comes back to
the hot dog classification is 99% the
not hot dog classification is less than
1% so just about any threshold this
would classify it as a hot dog and not
as a not hot dog another example
here is the burritos here is my picture
URL of pictures of burrito with rice
from Wikimedia also a great source by
the way of images searching in Wikimedia
and this one is classifying it as a hot
dog at 10% and a not hot dog at about
80% so with the threshold somewhere in
the 50 70 % range it would would make
their classification correctly there's
not so much fun to do it just from the
our command line let's actually build an
app to do this there are several ways
you can encompass these predictions into
an application you can do it offline so
if you wanted to run it's sort of on a
server that wasn't connected to the
Internet or
more realistically on a phone
application you can export it as core ml
so to run an iPhone I can export it as
tensorflow so to run Android you can
also export it as onyx which are running
lots of different platforms this is a
general open-source framework for
defining trains predictive models in
with deep learning or you can export it
to a container which will run or
anything like a Raspberry Pi for example
then I think about that it's fast you
don't need any internet connection to
make it work but you are limited in the
size of the underlying you will network
that you use just for performance reason
on these small devices and so there's
something called the compact model in
custom vision which is a very small
general model but works pretty well for
these offline applications or you can do
it online if you're connected to the
Internet you can connect through the
REST API and you show me show me doing
saw me doing that from our a minute ago
and I'm gonna use those same functions
to connect to a shiny app just through
the endpoints that the service provides
me the code for the shining app is
available on github but let me just show
you how it works first of all let's
start with an image that is not one of
those classification this is my dog easy
here's the URL the picture of him from
the blog and you can see that even at
the 50% threshold he's very confidently
classified as not hot dog he's a hot dog
but he's not a hot dog all right there
is here's another example so this is a
hot dog I come from Chicago this would
never be classified as a hot dog in
Chicago nonetheless my app does indeed
classify it as a hot dog so it's
interpreting this particular thing as a
hot dog
another example these are some spring
rolls and you can see my app is
classifying that as a hot dog this is a
good example of a Mis classification
here it is depending on the threshold
I've got a slider over here which you
Commendatore like manipulate in the
shiny app that I bump that threshold up
to up to
up to next slide please
there we go you move this slider up and
down and you can see that the threshold
for that particular picture was 52% but
this is a good example like ever you're
finding things and misclassified that
shouldn't be this is a good prompt to
you to put some more images into the
training set and retrain so I can better
discriminate these types of things I
would add some pictures of spring rolls
to my training set and hopefully this
kind of thing would be fixed all right
it was really nice building this next
slide please
it was really nice booting this as a
shiny app really easy to do as well and
one of the really nice features of shiny
is setting reactive inputs and if you
haven't played around with it so the
long story short is that when I call out
through the API
it's Katia's the values that it has
previously requested so that as I move
that slider back and forth it's not
going back to the API anytime it just
uses the categorization from the API and
changes the output in the shiny app
that's really nice because it saves me
money because it doesn't have to make it
query back to the API any API every time
well actually in this case doesn't
matter because I'm using the free tier
of custom vision which is completely
free up to two classifications per
second which is enough for an API for a
shiny app but if you have a sort of
production application you can do it for
ten cents at once and for every ten
classifications all right so that's it
if you want to find whoops next slide
please
I'm just to summarize it's really easy
to do these transfer it's transfer
learning classifications using the
custom vision de AI app I was really
surprised at how few images you need
like I said I just leaned it less than
200 so build that app it's really fast
it just takes seconds actually rather
than days you would required to build up
a complete custom of computer vision
network from scratch and you can do it
either offline or as a REST API and it
can drive it from are with the HDH TTI
package answer on the next slides you'll
be able to find the github repository
where you can get all the code for the
classification and the app if you want
to try it to go to custom vision AI and
we do need an Azure account even though
it's free you can get a free account of
this link here which will also give you
200 credits if you're $200 in credit if
you're a new user
to do anything you want on Asia thank
you
[Applause]